[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
débrief des questions au gouvernement
les députés avaient eu la primeur du
plan de déconfinement le 7 mai dernier
et bien aujourd'hui ils ont tout fait
pour obtenir des précisions sur le plan
de soutien au secteur automobile
au moment même où emmanuel macron
faisait ces annonces pas moins de cinq
questions lors de cette séance avec le
socialiste guillaume garot du côté des
républicains michel vialay bruno myle
yens pour le modem côté communiste
sébastien jumel
et puis pour la république en marche
damien pichereau la filière automobile
vit probablement la plus grave crise de
son histoire avec un marché en chute de
90% au mois d'avril et des difficultés
d'approvisionnement logistique
ralentissant voire stoppant les chaînes
de production de nos usines
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous
détailler les contours du plan de
relance automobile annoncée ce jour par
le président de la république nous
n'avons jamais été aussi proches de
connaître les mesures du plan de relance
automobile mais je veux pouvoir vous
dire ici qu'il comporte trois axes
principaux le premier axe vise à
améliorer la qualité de l'offre
il s'agit pour répondre à la question de
comment faire en sorte que les français
puissent acheter des voitures fabriquées
en france de faire en sorte d'améliorer
le coût de revient de cette fabrication
pour ce faire c'est l'investissement
dans l'appareil de production dans
l'usiné du futur que nous allons
accompagner de manière massive
le deuxième axe il vise effectivement
accompagné la demande et on le sait il
faut accompagner l'émergence de la
filière électrique peut être pas
seulement celle de l'hybride
rechargeable
s'agissant du troisième axe il s'agit de
relocaliser les productions qui sont
compétitives en france cela veut dire
dans le cadre d'une charte entre les
donneurs d'ordre et les sous-traitants
de systématiquement considérer la france
comme un site possible de production et
de regarder les éléments qui nous manque
en termes de compétitivité pour les
combler pour les combler avec un soutien
je dirais des collectivités locales de
l'état ensemble et faire en sorte de
relocaliser notamment toutes les
activités autour de la traction
électrique moteur électrique
cris électrique au coeur de cette séance
de questions au gouvernement
l'organisation du second tour des
élections municipales on sait désormais
qu'il se tiendra le 28 juin prochain
mais la crainte pour beaucoup de députés
c'est que les électeurs ne se déplace
pas échaudé par ce qui s'est produit
lors du premier tour la députée les
républicains josiane corps naulleau a
donc soumis une proposition à christophe
castaner qui s'est montré assez ouvert
vous allez le voir le premier tour des
élections municipales qui s'est déroulé
au début du confinement a fortement été
perturbé et enregistré un très faible
taux de participation pour un scrutin
qui d'habitude mobilise des électeurs et
les électrices beaucoup de personnes
âgées notamment ne se sont pas déplacés
par peur de contracter le virus
il est aujourd'hui urgent d'offrir à
chaque citoyen la possibilité d'exprimer
son choix par correspondance
en complément du vote physique qu'il
n'est évidemment pas question de
remettre en cause et qui doit rester le
moyen principal de voter allez vous
monsieur le premier ministre prend des
décisions qui s'imposent pour
l'autoriser lors des élections
municipales du 28 juin prochain afin
d'avoir la participation la plus large
possible
il nous faut faciliter toutes les
conditions qui permettront dans un cadre
légal ou dans un cadre réglementaire qui
peut évoluer d'ici le jour de l'élection
qui permettra de faire en sorte que un
maximum de français puissent voter le
vote par procuration et nous évoquerons
demain avec les assurances données les
modalités de développement
le vote par correspondance qui est une
hypothèse qui avait été pratiqué en
france jusqu'en 1975 les parlementaires
de l'époque avait souhaité y mettre un
terme pour des raisons d' usage
frauduleux mais nous devons aujourd'hui
ne rien exclure sur ce sujet et c'est
dans cet esprit que nous travaillerons
demain avec les associations d'élus avec
les partis politiques et peut-être dans
les jours qui viennent avec vous pour
mettre en oeuvre la capac des capacités
nouvelles pour développer et garantir le
vote je vous remercie
et puis il a été aussi question des
écoles et de ses enfants qui n'ont pas
été jugé prioritaire pour retourner en
classe au mois de mai qu'en sera-t-il en
juin qu'en sera-t-il aussi de ses
parents qui sont au chômage partiel et
dont les enfants ont retournerons
las mais à mi temps seulement autant de
questions relayées par le président du
groupe id jean christophe lagarde et
auquel edouard philippe a répondu
monsieur le premier ministre je pense
que beaucoup de français attendent de
savoir comment ça fonctionne à partir de
la semaine prochaine
lorsqu'ils veulent scolariser leurs
enfants mais que les communes les
départements ou les régions ne sont pas
en situation de le faire si les
indicateurs restent bien orientés et je
le dis là aussi avec prudence c'est une
décision qui sera prise je dis j'aurais
l'occasion de communiquer sur ce point
jeudi après midi
si les eaux si les indicateurs restent
bien orientés alors nous pourrons sans
doute organiser une ouverture un peu
plus vaste des écoles faire en sorte que
les règles sanitaires puisse s'adapter
toujours avec prudence mais s'adapter à
ces nouvelles conditions
ce qui permettra d'accueillir je
l'espère et encore une fois je dis si
les indicateurs restent bien orientées
plus d'élèves à l'école de faire en
sorte que plus de professeurs reviennent
savez qu'il ya 50 % des professeurs qui
sont revenus assurés leur court
physiquement en présentiel
évidemment si on va cueillir plus et là
il faut que plus de professeurs puissent
revenir mais il faut que ça se passe
dans d'excellentes conditions
si c'est le cas c'est un grand si mais
si c'est le cas alors le nombre de ceux
qui vont se trouver dans la situation
vous décrivez va mécaniquement diminuer
à partir du 2 juin mais pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient faire en sorte que leurs
enfants soient accueillis à l'école et
qu'ils ne pourraient pas voir leurs
enfants accueillis à l'école sauf pour
des raisons de capacité soit parce que
on ne peut plus les accueillir on ne
peut pas les accueillir à ce moment
alors pour cela et pour cela seulement
lorsqu'ils ont une attestation qui
permettra d'établir le fait que leur
enfant ne peut pas être accueillis ils
pourront continuer à bénéficier des
dispositions relatives au chômage
partiel
voilà c'est tout pour ce débrief des
questions au gouvernement de ce mardi 26
mai on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
d'ici là portez vous bien
[Musique]